[Music]  kicking off et's Kardashian ketchup  Kourtney and Kylie sex it up on snapchat  Kylie flaunted her figure in some undies  at what looked to be a photo shoot while  Kourtney gave us this her glam teens  view of her cleavage while they get her  ready we love it Kourt also shared this  stevie pic on Instagram looking like a  total beach babe really cute  then there's kendall Jenner who has some  thoughts on Cindy Crawford's daughter  Kaia Gerber Kaia covers the new issue of  love magazine and get this kendall  actually took the pic and inside she has  this to say about her stunning  up-and-coming competition quote listen  we're all trying to get all our work in  now before she hits the scene when that  happens we'll all go broke there's just  so many people from my generation that  have been like it's this new era of  models which it's so weird to figure out  but I mean there's just so many amazing  people and you really get to see into  their lives